[Música]
i
bueno venimos de plantar nuestro árbol
ni nada más ni nada menos que número
150.000
todo comenzó cuando apenas tenía 20 años
perteneciente como dijo miguel a una
pequeña localidad llamada villa bonita
y siendo un joven que vive lejos de las
grandes oportunidades tanto laborales
como estudiantiles que ofrecen las
grandes ciudades
y bueno desde la fundación de la que soy
parte me propusieron trabajar de que
quería unirme a un conjunto de personas
para realizar que estaban realizando
talleres de educación ambiental en el
municipio del campo ramón
misiones curiosamente acepté sin saber
que iba a ser una actividad en la cual
me sentiría muy identificado y que hoy
en día la realizó con mucho entusiasmo
a la fundación que pertenezco se llama
fundación bosques nativos para la
biodiversidad y bueno surge es debido al
problema de la degradación de los
bosques y la pérdida de la biodiversidad
dentro de la selva paranaense más
precisamente del monte misionero
que a su vez genera
perdidas o impactos negativos sobre los
cursos hídricos de nuestra provincia
todo esto muchas veces tiene diferentes
problemáticas que se relacionan con por
ejemplo con con la regulación de las
diferentes leyes nacionales ambientales
como por ejemplo la 26.331 que trata
sobre los presupuestos mínimos para la
protección de los bosques nativos
argentinos o bien la ley 13 mil 272 que
habla sobre la defensa de la riqueza
forestal todo esto tiene que ver con que
hace aproximadamente 100 años atrás la
selva paranaense se extendía a lo largo
de un millón de kilómetros cuadrados
como ven en la imagen satelital en el
mapa se extendía al sur de brasil este
de paraguay toda la provincia de
misiones y la parte norte de la
provincia de corrientes
y que hoy
a transcurrir los al pasar los años se
fue reduciendo a solamente 54 mil
kilómetros
cuadrados quedando así
es un momento para que ustedes
reflexionen de que estamos haciendo bien
o lo que estamos haciendo más
sí
la fundación tiene diferentes
formas de actuar o diferentes puntos de
partida no es cierto que quiere lo que
realmente fue como un detonante y que
hoy en día trabajan en actividades de
reinserción
también de investigación
y por último protección de la flora y
fauna de la selva misionera
personalmente he participado en el
dictado de diferentes talleres y
talleres de educación ambiental para que
valga la redundancia
en los años 2013 y 2014 y posteriormente
en los años 2015 y 2016 en la que se
realizó un proyecto educativo ambiental
de seguimiento que se llamó
la onda paso de onda
que básicamente consistía en
pedir la idea era desarmar a los niños
que útiles que utilizaban las gomeras o
las ondas que usualmente la utilizaban
para cazar pequeños animalitos nuestra
idea era de qué
hacer un intercambio de que el niño nos
dé su comida y nosotros le damos un
binocular y una revista biodiversidad de
las aves de la selva misionera con la
idea de
en lugar de cazar en la selva que la
contemplé
entre otros proyectos debido a que tenga
que con relación a la reforestación de
la selva o de los bosques nativos dentro
de la república argentina la fundación
tuvo diferentes lugares de los sitios de
acción siendo todo el litoral argentino
los bosques patagónicos los bosques
secos del noa que va desde mendoza hasta
jujuy y la región pampeana
nuestros objetivos generales son
promover la regeneración de los bosques
nativos argentinos
alentar la restauración de la
biodiversidad y por último apoyar las
investigaciones científicas argentinas
actualmente la relación que poseo con
esta fundación es de colaborador
voluntario
focalizando me en concientizar
ambientalmente a diferentes estudiantes
y a la población en general de dentro de
nuestra provincia
en los diferentes talleres realizados en
el municipio del campo ramón básicamente
mi tarea fue la de divulgador de la
biodiversidad misionera
que hoy aproximadamente cuenta con
aproximadamente unas 3.000 especies de
vegetales incluyendo o como por ejemplo
el lapacho
el para rosa o en la yerba mate y
también aproximadamente unas 1.500
especies de animales englobando
mamíferos reptiles peces y aves
y también comentaba en esos talleres de
cómo comenzaba a cambiar la vida de los
pobladores en donde la fundación se
desempeñaba como por ejemplo en
actividades de reforestación o también
la recuperación de las cuencas hídricas
mediante
la restauración con las especies
vegetales
un aspecto que es muy valorado por los
colonos de nuestra zona que nos ayudan a
realizar y a mejorar
aquí podemos dar como una especie de
reflexión que aquí lo importante no es
la cantidad de proyectos que realicemos
o actividades hechas sino que lo
importante es el alto nivel de
importancia que la población en general
le dé a la conservación del ambiente en
donde se desarrolla
obviamente utilizando los recursos y
malgastar dos y es allí en donde
nosotros entramos en el juego como una
suerte de mediador entre el mundo
natural y el mundo del hombre
los retos los recursos que la fundación
maneja son como cualquier otra otra
institución
poseemos recursos económicos funcionamos
gracias a los aportes de nuestro
fundador y
mediante también diferentes donaciones
los recursos técnicos se basa en un todo
con un fuerte equipo de personas que nos
acompañan con muy buenos buena voluntad
y que se sienten parte de la
organización
también como recursos científicos y
tecnológicos
la fundación bosques posee un centro de
investigaciones en donde podemos
realizar estudios medioambientales
en donde cuenta con un laboratorio y
albergue propio para sus investigadores
y como instrumentos o elementos
tecnológicos por ejemplo tenemos
diferentes
un sencillo no son utensilios pero son
diferentes elementos como por ejemplo
las cámaras trampas o diferentes
elementos para medir la calidad del agua
como recursos materiales también
conseguimos dos viveros en donde
generamos nuestras propias nuestros
propios plantines para posteriormente la
replantación de las cuencas hídricas o
del monte misionero
y por último el capital más importante
que tenemos nosotros que vienen a ser
los que es el capital humano sí que
pueden ser tanto los voluntarios como en
mi caso o los investigadores que son
provenientes de mayormente del conicet
y bueno como para dar una tierra una
finalización
y mi perspectiva hacia el futuro además
de lograr mi título como técnico en
gestión ambiental
es poder seguir difundiendo a través de
la fundación que me permitió a
enriquecer mi vida cultural mi vida
profesional y privada
es poder seguir demostrando lo más que
se pueda el alto la alta importancia que
tiene la conservación del ambiente en
todos sus contextos ya que con su
degradación la vida sería cada vez más
dificultades muchas gracias
[Aplausos]